so Trump Care 3.0 is dead Republicans
decided yesterday they're not even going
to vote on it they knew they didn't have
the votes there was no point in actually
holding the vote that they seemed
desperate to have before September 30th
after which they would need 60 votes in
order to pass it rather than just the 51
votes that they were initially seeking
and at this point we have to be asking
the question why do they keep trying to
repeal Obamacare right I mean we have
another failure to repeal Obamacare the
third major failure during Trump's
administration that the eighth month
that he's been in office so far and any
normal person would be asking the
question at this point well why not just
stop trying to repeal the Affordable
Care Act
the simple answer we've been hearing is
campaign promise right making Obama care
better which seems to be the most
logical thing right now we have a system
that's in place it's the for-profit
employer connected health care system
there's really no chance of something
like medicare-for-all passing something
that Bernie Sanders has proposed under
the republican-controlled House Senate
in White House so what if we said right
now the best move is improve the aspects
of Obamacare that are not functioning
that well and one reason is there's been
a promise from many Republicans for
years as well as many of the Republicans
that ran for 2016 and from Donald Trump
to repeal and replace the Affordable
Care Act so that's like the simple layer
one explanation but there's a lot more
to it it's not just voters who have
heard the promise and want to see the
people they voted for I guess check off
a list of putting some successes up on
the board but it's donors Republican
donors really want the Affordable Care
Act repealed and an anonymous Republican
senator told POLITICO that Mitch
McConnell the Senate Majority Leader
might be returning to health care yet
again and even more in what's left of
2017 to show donors that the Republicans
in the Senate are trying because then I
guess for re-election purposes they
could say hey we've been trying Senate
Republicans were actually warned at a
private meeting that fundraising was not
going particularly well for them in part
because donors are disappointed that
they don't really have accomplishments
under Trump to tout and to brag
about that's according to the New York
Times and then the Washington Post has
reported that senators have been faced
with quote an unrelenting barrage of
confrontations with some of their
closest supporters donors and friends
over the multiple failures to repeal the
Affordable Care Act
this changes votes write the impact of
money and donors let me talk about one
example Dean Heller right Dean Heller is
a moderate Republican from Nevada Las
Vegas is in Nevada big Republican donors
Sheldon Adelson and Steve Wynn are in
Nevada and Dean Heller
oddly enough switched from being against
repealing the Affordable Care Act to
being in favor not only of a repeal but
specifically in favor of the Gramm
cassidy bill which is now dead in the
water reportedly after Sheldon Adelson
and Steve Wynn constituents and major
donors of Dean Heller's got on the phone
with the guy and were not particularly
friendly right I think we can read
between the lines but they stated
they're not pleased with what's going on
and Dean Heller better get in line and
try to get this thing repealed Steve
Schmidt you might remember he ran
Senator John McCain's presidential
campaign back in 2008 pretty astute
political analyst and strategist a
Republican one at that he said to Vox
that he's concerned that donors the
priorities of big Republican donors are
what is dictating legislative priorities
and a lot of the priorities seem to be
unpassable legislation like a repeal of
Obamacare so this is really pretty bad
and it tells us a lot about why we see
these efforts and we always hear about
the exceptions but I mean the rule is
that most of these Republicans will just
support the bill no matter what even as
a seventeen percent approval rating and
I think Senator Chuck Grassley from Iowa
said it best he said that he could give
you ten reasons why he shouldn't support
the Graham Cassidy bill yet he was going
to support it anyway and I think it has
to do with promises to voters but also
promises the donors as well and you
might say well hold on a second David
Democrats and Republicans they're
different on some issues they're similar
on other issues but everybody receives
donations from health insurance
companies and pharmaceutical companies
Republicans and Democrats both do that
so why is it that the donors are
dictating GOP
of priorities because I'm not talking
about the insurance companies and
pharmaceutical companies I'm talking
about rich individual Republicans who
want Obamacare repealed either for
personal reasons right uh someone who
owns big casinos like Steve Wynn and
will own them in other states as well
including the one that's coming up here
in Massachusetts it could be just about
his own pockets and checkbook it's not
about health insurance companies or big
pharma and it also just seems to be what
some Republicans want they wanted this
repealed they're donating big bucks and
they expect it to be done period and
clearly there are Republicans who get it
they get that these bills are
fundamentally flawed and and it's
possible and in fact I've mentioned this
before we are still sort of talking
about Obamacare like we have our health
care system and this thing's stuck on to
it that is called Obamacare that we
could remove at any time but I think
more realistic is that it's been seven
years now right we have to be thinking
about Obamacare just as part of the
health care system and if we're gonna
make make changes it can't just be get
rid of this thing that we think of as an
appendage because it's not an appendage
anymore right if you're 33 years old or
younger you have been out of your
parents health care system only under
Obamacare that's a lot of people
everybody on the planet who's 33 or
younger has had health insurance during
a time when they can be either under
their parents plan or they are out
meaning 26 or older with Obamacare as
the status quo that's going to make it
really tough to get rid of this thing
and we absolutely should be debating
health care but you have to remember
that money in politics and I guess you
can throw gerrymandering in there as
well are the issues that Eclipse all
other issues and that's why I think we
really have to get to those first yeah
and and those impact every single issue
and from from a sort of like practical
point of view in order to do what it is
that Republicans some Republicans and
Trump
I guess want to do you need to appeal to
both susan collins republican from maine
one type of republican Republican and
Rand Paul Republican senator from
Kentucky as far as Republicans go it's
hard to get Republicans more
ideologically different than Susan
Collins and Rand Paul I don't know how
you put together a bill that will appeal
to both of them and then you have the
Mavericks who sometimes stand on
principle like Senator John McCain yeah
and and he seems to you this time have
come around we didn't know a lot big
deal being made out of how John McCain
would ultimately vote ultimately it
ended up not even coming to a vote and
and yet again when we go back to it we
go okay repeal Obamacare donors money in
politics right we're back to money in
politics once again the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership